peacemaker is free and so are we to talk
about the show that is welcome to podly
the official peacemaker podcast from hbo
max in dc and stick around because we're
going to be chatting with james gunn and
you don't want to miss that let's get
into it
why is there a bald eagle in your car
that's equal eagerly is your pet eagle
yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
what is up everyone i'm your host fiona
nova and i'm iffy wady way and each week
on podly we'll be diving into this
badass
wild hilarious ride of a show that is
known as peacemaker and we're just also
going to be talking with some great
creatives uh behind the scenes and also
some of the cast yeah yeah but you know
before we get started i did want to
point out look
this is a companion podcast for the show
everything in conjunction with the show
that we're doing is free game so do if
you have not watched episode one yet
hit pause go watch it and then come talk
to us after and so on and so forth so
just so you know spoilers ahead because
we're assuming you went ahead and you
already watched the show this is the
first time i've been like hearing about
peacemaker and knowing his origin story
seriously and i mean we've seen him in
suicide squad but we were introduced to
him who is he what makes him tick i know
the show definitely gets into it so
let's talk about it let's do it
[Music]
so
first things first peacemaker survived
he survived
which is something you'd know if you
stayed till after the credits and saw
the same yeah you know we got a little
tease yeah yeah we got a little tease
and you know
it really kind of teed up what you're
gonna expect in the episode first thing
he's like i'm i gotta get out of here
yeah i gotta get out of it there was
that really great back and forth with
the janitor yeah
which is amazing you're kind of monkey
to be a superhero right both superheroes
have a gymnast body they're ready to go
i'm ready to go what superhero are you
peacemaker oh
peacemaker yes you're that racist
superhero you only kill minorities man i
killed a fair amount of white people too
the ratio is suspect is all i have to
say
and then like next you know he's back
he's back home he thinks he's in the
clear and then boom the cruiser
of course he's not in the clear and then
we got the amazing intro yeah yeah i
remember watching it and i was like oh
this is going to be that type of show
because the dance sequence and everyone
just taking it so seriously it felt like
a musical yeah i know it was almost like
a fever dream i was like is this what is
this what peacemaker is seeing yeah
personally i just think that intro fits
perfectly with the theme of this show
yeah um it's kind of just ridiculous and
out there and then the eagle at the end
that we will know as eagly yeah the cast
looked great everyone looks great so you
get this amazing intro and then you're
introduced to um
danielle brooks yeah and her significant
other which is great she has the cute
dog she's new
you know it's yeah it's it's a fun
moment you get excited like it really
does feel almost like the beginning of a
heist move where you're learning the
crew because you know we have the folks
that we remember from the suicide squad
and now we got a new
person joined
and now we're gonna see what's going to
happen which
what happens is
peacemaker
gets kind of ambushed in his trailer
yeah right by burn yeah and he's and
they they need him for us a special
mission yeah when he goes to see his dad
and he goes and and he's we meet eagerly
you know he's he was just in the garage
right he was in the garage posed up
just he was there yeah he was there his
dad is um
interesting his dad's interesting
interesting it doesn't seem like a very
loving dad i don't think we're supposed
to like this one i don't think this
guy's great what happens next now the
team is kind of setting up shop the team
that wants to recruit peacemaker at that
point we don't really know what they
what they need for him so we're trying
to figure that out his dad hooked him up
with the helmet and that's where we kind
of learned that he he's kind of supplied
by his dad so it did bring this
interesting thing where it's like yeah
this is someone who we know is a bad
person yeah but it's where peacemaker
gets all his gear from but yeah you see
like he begrudgingly gives you know
peacemaker a new suit he pulls up in the
suit they're kind of like oh my god oh
there was a line like a cosplay line
yeah yeah
did this [ __ ] really show up in full
cosplay mode this is the guy waller's
giving us
but then also yeah because they're like
you know we're trying to be these
undercover agents and you're walking in
straight up in a hero's speaker that's
kind of like the fun of this show is it
kind of feels like just like a regular
like agent secret agent show at times
and then you realize that this is a
world in which people are
so disillusioned by heroes because they
see them you know this is weird people
in costume it's nothing it's nothing too
weird yeah we're like that's just a hero
it's the dc universe so like a guy
walking into the diner like oh that's
just you know peacemaker yeah that's
just peacemaker would you see if you saw
a guy like that would you be like that's
a hero or is that just some kind of you
know i i'd have to see a reaction
because you know i do see the
you got the dove of peace on the chest
uh but that helmet is menacing uh he
looks like he can headbutt me and end me
it's very shiny yeah it's very important
he could blind you yeah it really can
yeah we get into the diner we're getting
to know the team a little more yeah and
he and
we're finding out that uh peacemaker
uh he's horny well first you know i'm
gonna give peacemaker some credit first
it was the these random gross dudes at
the bar who came over and was hitting on
her in a weird way and then we saw just
how capable she was because she just
took them down like it was nothing yeah
and then peacemaker came through well
the thing is is that like peacemaker is
so
god you kind of feel bad for him because
he's just so literal he has obviously
bad social cues yeah there's there was a
level of openness with being like i've
been in prison a long time you know i'm
not looking for love i'm just trying to
bump our genitals together right right
lucky for him
he still did guilty he did get somebody
which
which then brings us to that happens
he's at the girls place
they're banging they're at the girl's
place
there's this huge fight that happens
yeah that erupts and i want to go before
the fight before the because i
before
the fight
what did you think was going to happen
you know i felt it and i got something
oh yeah no something was going to happen
yeah it was too something was going but
then he had his little dance sequence
naked singing into a vibrator yeah and
then she came up with a knife and just
started
slapping slash slash
very physically nimble yeah like this is
this is this was very obviously
not just someone not a human yeah
yeah and growling and tossing him
through and it's like a huge fight scene
and it goes all the way outside when
he's trying to run away yeah and then we
we find the power of the helmet because
we didn't see you know we didn't see all
that the helmet could do we did we did
the movie yeah
we saw it and we got kind of a tease of
oh the helmet actually does something
yeah because again someone who hasn't
read the comics or don't doesn't really
understand or know peacemaker i didn't
think the helmet had anything to do with
it i thought it was like just a helmet
and it essentially blows her up yeah
it's the sonic boom sonic boom it blows
not just her a huge large radius of the
parking lot yeah and the police are
coming
and that's where we left off yeah that's
legitimately where we left off and we
came in with not a lot of questions
we leave with more questions and not a
lot of answers why why wait any longer
we can just ask james gunn yeah he's
just he's just gonna be here yeah and
we're gonna ask him some questions and
we're also gonna ask questions that you
have all asked yeah yeah we went ahead
and picked one question that the
community asked and we're going to ask
james gunn for you because you know
we're a pod for the people exactly yeah
for the people for the people for the
people let's go talk to james
[Music]
we are joined with the man behind the
madness james gunn who is the writer and
director of the show welcome welcome to
the show about your show hey guys hey
hey how's it hanging
the show about my show
and i've and i'm in strangely i'm going
to start a podly podcast about your show
absolutely so that we can have a podcast
about the podcast good great idea i
think i was thinking last night i don't
think i've been this excited about
people seeing some it's such an
interesting thing tv too because you
know it's not uh people just you know
need to turn on their tv and watch it if
they have hbo max and suicide squad was
on tv yeah and more people saw i mean
like just everyone had seen it like
three days later everyone i knew in the
world had seen it and just
and so the difference between something
being on tv and something being um in a
theater is so it's so different so i'm
very excited about it coming out and
people getting a chance to see it and i
don't think people really know what to
expect i definitely didn't know what to
expect yeah i know what did you expect i
didn't know too much about peacemaker i
think as someone who's like new to this
yeah no i was hyped going into
peacemaker because you know i'm a i'm a
reveal myself i'm a james gunn head yeah
back to the trauma stuff as a comedy guy
i was like all on board and then just
even seeing like the way you use music
and peacemaker the same way i was like
oh
james gunn enjoys music that's one thing
i do know i love music so much but what
i really love doing is like scratching
this ish itch of music that we know but
don't notice and is underappreciated and
so i feel better about the peacemaker
soundtrack than i do
of any soundtrack since guardians 1.
because guardians 1 we were like taking
these old 1970s am hits that people
might recognize they might know the name
of the song but they almost certainly
don't know the name of the artist and
kind of bringing them to the surface and
putting them in a completely different
context and in this show it's taking
hair metal basically or yes sleaze metal
is or glam metal and and taking that
music and giving it a spotlight and it's
a mix between these old bands uh you
know like in the first episode which i
guess we're talking about the choir boys
um and then you know new bands uh and
kind of mixing them up that are from
like there's a lot of european sleeves
metal bands today that are actually
really good they're actually overall
much better than the hair metal bands
that i grew up with um but being able to
give that music you know that's so out
of fashion in america a chance to shine
a little is is one of the fun things
about this show the music was i i loved
what you said about how like you're
trying to bring unknown music or unknown
sounds to to a franchise like peacemaker
or like a big franchise like that which
is i love that that's why what is it
about peacemaker as just like a
character that appeals to you that made
you want to do this i you know i think
that it was a lot of different things
number one
i loved uh the captain america tv movie
from when i was a kid
and i'm like what would a really [ __ ]
up version of that be like so rightfully
so if you ever go back and see it it's
it's terrible but as a child i loved it
so i'm like what could in my brain what
was that show you know and then you take
that to sort of this extreme place and
that's peacemaker so that's part of it
the other part of it is just he's i'm
interested in superheroes that are
different whether it's
their
superpower that's different like rat
catcher two you know she has a
superpower that we don't normally see
control of animals that's much more
interesting to me than all these people
shooting ray guns out of their hands you
know just so many guys but peacemaker is
like he's kind of a bad guy he's kind of
yeah he's kind of a piece of crap but
he's also he does have a point you know
he really does have a point so i can see
i can see where he's coming from and i
also can think that he's wrong and that
makes an interesting character for me
and then the other thing was i loved
working with john on the suicide squad
and yeah when we made that movie
a lot of the other characters get more
background than than christopher smith
does bloodsport does ratcatcher 2 does
polkadot man does
um
so it was about john and i talked a lot
about where he came from and who he was
and how awkward he is even in that group
of people that start to bond he's still
awkward he's the guy that still feels
left out and he has this little moment
this one night where he's dancing at la
gatita
where he feels like he's maybe a part of
the group and kind of starting to let go
and then he goes and destroys it all
because of his ideals and this is a guy
who's being crushed by his ideals his
his ideals are ruining his spirit
and to me that's the central story of
the show is a guy whose ideals are
crushing his his self
and who he is and so getting to see that
from you know really close
but also john is really funny and
um we did a lot of improv and funny
things on suicide squad but in a movie
you really got to move from scene to
scene to scene to scene to scene to
scene so i thought it would be fun to be
able to take that character and stretch
him out a little bit really see how he
is see how he ticks who he is and then
allow ourselves to have more humor allow
ourselves to have more drama
and and just be able to get to see all
these different facets of this character
like yeah what was it like to be able to
like really embrace getting weird with
john cena i'm really really blessed in
my life to have the you know two of the
guys that are my closest
uh collaborators that i've worked with
are chris pratt and john cena and they
are legitimately two of the deepest
hardest kindest
guys with integrity and and john you
know below none he has so much integrity
he's such a good person he shows up 100
and i love i love that and because he
has that trust in me
and i have that trust in him we have a
very intimate relationship where i'm
able to tell him anything about his
acting if i think he's getting off base
somewhere i will tell him directly i
think he appreciates that because i am
so direct and uh and so we just trust
each other immensely as human beings
first and foremost and then secondarily
as as creative people um and so he he
puts his he puts his you know life in my
hands in terms of the life that he's
portraying on screen of of christopher
smith and uh and it makes it a lot
easier you know traveling through eight
episodes that's a long time to be
shooting somebody 131 days on this show
so it was fun well i mean okay so we got
peacemaker mm-hmm and then we've got
this amazing
sidekick that you that you had it was
eagley yeah yeah yeah what i loved it i
love it
is that is that like one like is he your
your favorite sidekick ever
because it is for me i love animals you
know so there always ends up to be a big
animal element and even sometimes the
animal is not an animal it's groot you
know so it's like but i love you know i
love sebastian and suicide squad but
eagley's eagly's a lot of fun because
he's not there's no sense sentimentality
to eagley like sebastian who's a rat is
much smarter than a normal rat would but
eagley is he's an eagle he's not much
eagles are smart animals but they aren't
people and uh and also eagley will bite
you just you know he just doesn't really
like anyone but peacemaker but he has
taken peacemaker on is sort of his child
in a way
and i think that that serves this
there's there's this thing with you see
a lot with people with dogs you know
people often can be these harsh just
really kind of bad people but with dogs
there can be really kind and that always
makes you go oh god maybe the person
isn't all bad because they're nice to
dogs now some the worst people are mean
to animals right
but some people have that and and that's
what i think christopher smith is like
with eagley that brings out this
softness that he has and he's completely
vulnerable and loving with eagle he
loves eagley and you see this different
side of him from episode one and i i
knew that when we were making this show
we're fighting a little bit against the
fact that people think peacemaker is a
piece of [ __ ] i mean it's one of the
things i hear the most online is why are
you making this show about peacemaker we
want it about this person or rat catcher
too or whatever but the truth is i found
peacemaker the most interesting in some
ways simply because those characters had
an or they had a change in that in
suicide squad bloodsport becomes a
better person by the end of suicide
squad peacemaker doesn't have that
and so to be able to see someone
intimately on that process
of becoming a different person better or
worse or whichever way this all goes
seeing that more intimately i thought it
gave us a deeper place to start with
peacemaker but i also knew that you know
people are not going to stick
you know with the show beyond a couple
episodes if they don't like peacemaker
if they don't have some feeling for
christopher smith so
i think giving him some of these things
his relationship with eagley seeing a
little bit about where he comes from
with what a piece of [ __ ] his father is
um and that you know like so many of us
we think we're terrible but then we look
at our parents and they're slightly
worse versions of ourselves you know so
he is improving upon where he came from
um
he's uh he's not as bad as his dad so i
think that maybe hopefully people will
see something about christopher smith
that they kind of love a little bit even
though he might push people away oh yeah
yeah
so you know we got to talk about that
opening number uh do you know the dance
from the opening credits by heart
i'm hoping the answer is yes yeah would
you like me to do it hold on
that was in the script from the
beginning um
i had um there's a woman by the name of
carissa barton who is
uh
who i hired to do the choreography for
us and
um
she happens to be the wife of my good
friend alan tudyk the the actor and
which was just a coincidence i didn't
know when i hired her but she did a
fantastic job i really just wanted
something very very weird it came in
from the i remember uh danielle brooks
coming into me i'm like what are we
doing like
what is this and i'm like just look
totally serious you're not having fun
you're not you're just be very very very
very serious and
you know telling carissa like we just
got to make the dance as ridiculous as
it can possibly be while they remain
completely serious but karissa really
helped me to put that together and put
that together she was the one that
designed it and she did an amazing job
and what one of the fun things that
you'll see as you watch the the episodes
of the series is it plays a different
role in every episode like i know people
are going to be able to skip over it i
hope they don't because it plays a
different role in every every series you
know like
you know it just always tells a
different story and you see as as our
story gets darker and deeper and more
sad that the dance itself kind of
becomes more sad and more serious and
less funny and so it's interesting to
see in that yeah oh yeah yeah and i mean
your stories often like showcase a lot
of empathy for like people in society
that we label as bad
you know so like can you talk a little
bit about the appeal of
just the bad guy in general i guess i
don't think of it as a bad guy i guess i
think of you know
there's there's there's good people in
this world and we love them this is my
catholic upbringing this is how i look
at the world right and then there's evil
people
yeah yeah
but then there are
all of us that are in between and i'm
that maybe you guys aren't you're
probably both very good i don't know but
i'm in between right i'm not perfect i'm
better than most but not great and um
and
i think it's really about finding
you know people finding the good in
themselves you know and i grew up i got
sober at an early age i was you know
around a lot of people who did a lot of
bad things i was a very bad kid and
you know finding the goodness in other
people so that you can empathize i think
is an important thing and that's a big
part of the show too i mean the
relationship between peacemaker and
adebayo um who both come from very very
different places in terms of what their
political beliefs are in terms of their
ideals
but who
have a
a a genuine joy in each other's company
and a genuine
friendship from the very beginning in
the first episode we see this thing that
plays out sort of like a meet cute and
so it's really about a friendship and
she laughs she laughs at his jokes and
she's probably the first person that
we've seen laugh at his jokes the whole
episode for sure but even through his
jokes and suicide squad nobody ever
laughed at what he had to say like she
thinks he's funny he's a doofus he has
believes a lot of stupid things
but she kind of likes him and he
definitely likes her and so that
friendship to me is the heart of the
show in so many ways listen i i will
also say as a gay woman i would be best
friends with a peacemaker
so you're all you're right on that
would you would you be uh yeah i think
so i think our humor i think our weird
humor would actually get along honestly
i don't think you're wrong well the
weird thing about peacemaker too is the
one thing he doesn't have any judgments
of is is sexuality like he himself is
twisted sexually this is all john cena
by the way i didn't think of i didn't
think i just thought peacemaker was like
probably a regular straight frat boy
type when i was writing him in the in
suicide squad but john kept bringing
this other element to him that was very
omnisexual he was he's a sexual omnivore
and uh and and we see peacemaker talk
about that mention that briefly to uh um
to a harcourt in the first episode so
it's not like peacemaker's a bad guy
either i mean
you know people constantly are writing
on twitter about how awful he is and how
mad he is that he killed rick flagg but
and i i may get [ __ ] for saying this but
man he was what he was doing he had a
reason for doing it he was he didn't
want
the the the d you know in he kills rick
flag in in uh suicide squad because
there's a piece of evidence that he
believes will cause the world a great
amount of disturbance yes and death and
violence
and he's covering up the truth so if you
believe in the truth being out there no
matter what yeah you definitely don't
agree with that but he's not a natural
rights perspective he's a utilitarian
you know he's comes from a utilitarian
perspective so he believes that you know
the world is better off without that bit
of information and if that means killing
a guy he really likes and looks up to
he's willing to do that um and then
let's also say rick flag does try to
strangle peacemaker peacemaker wasn't
trying to kill rick flagg in that fight
it wasn't until
he was about to die that we got that
super cool uh sharded heart sequence
from like oh yeah
it's the best way to see someone die
well i just you know listen i i want you
know in these comments
in comic book movies you see people die
and they're not really dead and yeah
peacemaker is one of those people but
you know i wanted to
knock it home that was one of the things
we you know talked about the most in
suicide squad is that shot of rick
flag's heart getting pierced but to me
it's incred it makes it sadder because
we're not going to sit there and think
oh rick flack got up and walked away
from that after peacemaker was gone he
didn't we saw his heart explode into
blood like he's dead yeah um and that's
the reason for that shot all right now
to wrap this guest interview our
favorite segment which is eagley mail
okay got some fan submitted questions to
ask our guests and
this one is pretty interesting
[Music]
let's take a look
what does peace look like to peacemaker
what would the circumstances have to be
for him to say mission accomplished and
stand down
a complete world peace throughout the
world no more
violence whatever yeah i think
peacemaker knows that's not going to
happen
yeah okay i think you know he enjoys
making peace through violence you know
what i mean obviously he's a violent guy
so uh i think that's a part of his uh if
not his dna it's definitely a part of
his of how he grew up um and we'll learn
about that a lot more as the show goes
on we'll see
where
that sort of
violent streak came from and how he got
it if he he wants world peace he's got
yeah that's mission whatever whatever it
is whatever it is whatever
oh wow well thank you so much for
sitting down and talking with us for
this episode of podly uh it truly has
been a pleasure um and i'm super excited
two seconds how long was this yeah it
was great how are you going to get all
the information you need about these
episodes without three hours a piece
right yeah
but yeah thank you so much thanks guys
see you around talk to you soon bye
all right effie this is the segment
we've all been waiting for we're gonna
be announcing this week's
peace prize
[Music]
what we want to do with the peace prizes
is essentially want to give out the
prize to the moments of like badassery
heartwarming
school exciting moments um of an episode
and just give them the recognition they
deserve so for this week yeah yeah what
do you think
this week we're going to do the eagley
hug it's going to be a heartwarming
moment that we really enjoyed uh this
episode and that that felt like a hug
from eagerly it was so warm such a warm
eagly hug so what are you thinking the
scene that we would like to get this
priest prize yeah which was the scene
with adebayo and peacemaker they're
outside of the diner or restaurant and
uh they're finally getting that
connection oh yeah they're gonna be bffs
i feel it peacemaker is kind of coming
out of that interaction because they
were kind of dissing his outfit they
kind of treat him like he's dumb and he
he's kind of feeling that feeling
yeah and so he goes back to his car and
you know he's talking with eagerly who
is showing him some love
and you have someone like uh arabiyah
who wants to come up and try and connect
with them
because you know her mom has uh sent her
on a mission to uh
your mom being amanda wallace yeah yeah
on a mission specifically to uh
to uh get close with uh peacemaker but
it's interesting because you can't tell
if if it's like a real connection or if
it's yeah but i mean i don't know
something about adebayo feels like
genuine i feel like she doesn't really
know what she's getting herself into
yeah and i think just that that that
peacemaker and autobio scene kind of you
feel like they're probably both on the
same page they both don't really know
what they're getting themselves into but
they have to do it i think that scene
deserves that prize yeah i think at
least for this episode yeah so for the
first official peace prize it's going to
be that scene getting the eagley hug the
warm eagly warm eagley hey
hey bud
oh [ __ ] man i thought you said it was
friendly oh i thought you meant friendly
to me yeah i know it's friendly to you i
saw you pettit
you know you're so happy to see me today
wrap his wings around me and hug me an
eagle hugged you oh yeah yeah i call him
[ __ ] on that you don't want to
believe in miracles that's on you
you're neuro huh yeah but i know my [ __ ]
don't worry about that i've done a lot
of you know
notable things that's super vague
oh you hubbed up
huh
married yeah that's cool
i'm into old-fashioned stuff too you
know humble figurines and capital
punishment and
garbage pill kids and stuff
i i loved how i loved how she was just
like an eagle can hug
what are you talking about what are you
doing
what are you talking about i don't
believe yeah and and eagley is only nice
to peacemaker yeah and no one else
you know eagley is an eagle to everyone
else a friend to peace right that's a
peacemaker which honestly i think well
it's just the loyalty i think it's time
we get up out of here uh yeah so uh yeah
thank you for watching and listening to
podly the official peacemaker podcast
from hbo max and dc make sure to
subscribe and tune in for the next
episode where we break down episode
number two and we've got some sweet
merch you're gonna want some merch you
want to support okay you want to wear
some peacemaker merch
go to
shop.dcomics.com for the latest drops
you don't want to miss it and if you
want to get tapped into the source
material make sure you sign up for dc
universe infinite which will give you
access to all the peacemaker comics
suicide squad and everything in between
also don't forget to go ahead and follow
us on twitter instagram and facebook and
make sure you comment and tell us your
favorite moments from the episode and
make sure that you're up to date and
you're watching episodes of peacemaker
and podley on hbo max we'll see you next
time yeah we'll see you next time i'll
talk about we're gonna pe we're gonna
peace out yeah we're gonna peace out
see you on episode number two we're
gonna peace out
you